everyone who's come within a country
mile of a competitive shooter has at the
very least
heard of simple they have they've done
so towards that ramp they go
right into the weights of simple head
shot to sixer
no scope to rpk and another
he's throwing the rulebook
counter-strike away and he's completely
lighting them up this
is unbelievable simple with their
headshots from hell
he's got a triple he fakes it once and
just goes to check the window this is
all about timing
nitro does have a bottle of another
smoke so it could be really rough or
simple to actually get through this he's
going to throw the awp
oh my god simple what is happening
at this point i just want to take some
ct's out so they don't
they're not able to pick more weapons up
oh my god that's ridiculous from simple
how on earth has he done that he isn't
just arguably the greatest cs go player
of all time
he's one of the greatest fps phenoms
ever to touch a mouse and keyboard
a dome smashing deity who's worshiped
worldwide for his uncanny ability to
pull off disgusting
unthinkable feats all the time
there's a player right next to him on
his left and surely he gets taken down
here
he spots one oh what chris jay
somehow i don't know how heard him
through her oh my god that's so
smart from simple what but that's not
the only reason he's renowned
see in addition to being the undisputed
master of his craft
the inimitable alexander simple
castilliev
is also a bit of a meme and whether
you're some edgy silver two
e-gamer or some g-fueled fortnite
sad boy surely you must know that a play
cannot be deemed
truly sick unless it heralds the asking
of
one simple question
why are you bullying me
why are you bullying me no but for real
you can have it actually psych you
thought this kid dude he's so mad he's
so mad dude why are you bullying me
what you may not know is the story and
controversy
behind that question hey stop losing
rounds dude you keep talking to me shut
up
you suck you aim at the ground when you
run around you're so bad you need a tan
get some friends
the tale of how europe's most toxic yet
tantalizing prospect
became the most maligned and mistreated
import
north american counter-strike has ever
seen
i think in general his skill outweighs
his attitude
and i don't think he's always bad so why
is it that simple became the
bane of the region that he was supposed
to save how much of that hate was
deserved and is there a sense in which
it shaped him into the reformed
superstar that he
is today he can jump on those boxes but
instead he's gonna call
the first gets the frag but this is so
nice from liquid he's holding it and all
now has to do is check it
again simple that's simply not allowed
okay so before he was sasha the smasha
cs goes colloquially accepted goat
and the only man with almost as many
superstition montages to his name
as mvp medals simple was but an unproven
prodigy
known for two things the first was his
indescribable talent hell raisers it's
fallen apart for them forest gets lagged
as
simple as trying to chase them down but
this is not gonna go this is not
how it's supposed to go here for
hellraisers they are about to get
overwhelmed and
what looked like such a solid start to
their half has only resulted in what
five rounds
which i think is plenty but it but
obviously it's a little bit sad for them
because they could have had way more
so you got to give your credit to nip
for bringing you this far back it's
definitely very cool
now as long as they don't find simple
fight civil one at a time there should
be no way out of this especially not for
just 20 seconds here so
they just got to stay safe otherwise
it's that's would be the worst way for
nlp to lose
us around and that would actually be
pretty pretty big if that happens
10 seconds molotov goes in the corner
he's gonna try and see if he can look
for the man in here and fryeburg goes
down
five seconds four seconds he's gonna go
straight for the plant and he's going to
get it as well
now it's get right he's actually
revealed his position simple really
right here
he's got the triple he just needs the
time and get right there he pre-fires
and he's going to get it
oh my god the second was his
incessant toxicity
[Music]
thank you for a game dumas thank you
really nice to play with you you're
playing like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you see simple's fighting roots ran deep
even as a kid
he'd been a feisty little rascal
after being kicked from his first real
roster hellraisers on account of his
caustic persona simple found himself on
flipside tactics
and on that team he became both flashier
and in spite of his past misconducts
even
flamiere
this wasn't just in official matches
mind you simple's antics got
so bad that at one point he was handed a
7 day ban from
fpl's teamspeak server user in your
channel was banned from the server
what the [ __ ]
people was banned for seven days from
the server by tiles
my friend you need to calm down this is
one weak warning
in spite of his obvious transgressions
simple continued to solidify himself
as arguably the most gifted up-and-comer
in the pro scene i'm not gonna find that
oh my god there it is like
what is that what is up with this guy
and following his heavily publicized
departure from flipside he made a real
effort at reform
you can watch every my stream you can
watch any pro stream
when i'll be here uh
you see me from another site you know i
listen to us i listen here
hiccups at me and then thanks to his
newly formed friendship with hiko
he was given the opportunity to
represent his first
tier one organization all the way across
the pond
hell-bent on achieving his dream he put
everything in his life
on hold and said yes now at this point
north american cs had yet to form its
first
real super squad liquid signed simple
realizing that if they could get his
toxicity under control
he could be their salvation so the orc
greeted him with an extremely warm
welcome but just because liquid was
happy with his arrival
didn't mean that everyone was the other
pros he'd been brought into eclipse
weren't exactly in love with the idea of
this toxic teenager with a god complex
being
touted as their lord and savior of
course that wasn't simple's fault
what was simple's fault was the way he
chose to carry himself
what are you doing you [ __ ] idiots
let's go together and win or
[Music]
kill someone why i kill everyone you
[ __ ]
you see simple was a true perfectionist
the kind of player who interpreted every
little incompetence as a blatant throw
and was terrible at expressing his
frustrations in a constructive way
so he tended to evoke the ire of the
irritated americans he'd been forced to
play with
and from there a meme was born one of
the
holiest dankest and most ubiquitous
utterances in the
whole of cs go peter why you
what he's doing why are you bullying me
you [ __ ] [ __ ] why you bully me
everyone asking now
to be fair that interaction was actually
held to be in good fun the problem
was that shortly after that people
started legitimately
attacking simple over the stupidest [ __ ]
[Music]
it didn't matter that he wasn't the one
who started any of this [ __ ] the
community kept
going after him knowing that eventually
they'd get a rise out of him
but it wasn't until simple found himself
playing with
ryan freakazoid abbadir who fun fact
happens to be masquerading as stewie2k
it's a [ __ ]
that things really spiraled out of
control
chef why are you such a noob dude stop
baiting for kills did you suck
is that you don't have you don't even
know you're talking to
i don't think you have real life friends
do you have any balls or
nah he's like talking all night didn't
get scared person huh
man how you see your aim sucks
so bad you need a tan get some friends
the clip spread throughout the community
like wildfire
before long everyone had seen it and
people were taking
sides but most condemned freak claiming
that he'd crossed the line between
[ __ ] talking and actual bullying oh it
just goes to show how american
you know freak is right it's all about
the bullying baby
america bullies the rest of the world
freak bully's simple
it all comes around in a nice full
circle still there were those who came
to freak's defense people who claimed
that even though he may have taken
things
a little too far it was kind of
hypocritical to pretend all of a sudden
that simple was
innocent in all of this i'm not trying
to badmouth simple but he himself
is blatantly known to troll people
online and
call people noobs and you know kind of
bait people and then he's just able to
say he's joking but
to act like he's like a small little
frail kid that
can't handle himself when he just talks
plainly talks crap to people online all
the time to me was
hilarious and sure there might be some
merit to that
but there's also no denying that freak's
behavior was
downright cruel he's definitely in the
wrong like 100 percent obviously i think
everyone
everyone can see that freakazoid ryan i
call him ryan
is in the wrong and really
simple did nothing to ask for what
happened cloud9's manager
stunna was quick to issue an apology on
the team's behalf
followed soon after by freak's own
apology which
came off as disingenuous i'm making this
video
because last night with the incident was
simple
i was defending my friends and uh
i went too far i made a mistake
and i just want to apologize to simple
um i want to apologize to my team our
organization my teammates
and while simple's camp accepted these
apologies
it felt as if the damage had been done
it was like simple's walls had been torn
down and everyone was
finally afforded a window into the soul
of this
seemingly out of control teenager and
what they
saw surprised them my dream is
wake up in the morning in ukraine for
sure just
turn on my television and to hear that
[Music]
today everything good
no kills no dice no [ __ ] stupid
situation
it's peace no word my friend
and that's what i really want because
you know
[Music]
i'm doing [ __ ] a lot bad things i'm a
good person in
real life but sometimes
i'm trolling so hard in [ __ ] twitter
or cs and people don't understand me
sometimes i'm
writing [ __ ] for us with my bad english
and people don't understand this
so i just want the [ __ ] peace
in the [ __ ] world that's all i want
[Music]
there was no denying that since
migrating to the states
simple had become even more of a toxic
tyrannical [ __ ]
but it also became apparent why he
wasn't
evil he was just a kid who missed his
friends
his family his food his language
who'd left home for the first time in
his life in the hopes of fulfilling his
dream
only to get [ __ ] on by virtually
everyone around him who
like anyone struggled with the idea of
being
hated
and yet somehow he succeeded in spite of
it
jdm nade out in behind the back of the
site not to be spotted though or not to
be taken any damage it is still simple
though he's rotated over he's now coming
to life and it's gonna be a dread that
pops out late
suddenly around out of nowhere simple
saves it
believes that it's just simple so commit
to the plan no baits it out smartly so
gets edward and he knows that they're
trying to wrap back around onto him
smoke to allow him the freedom of
movement and also the chance to peak
spots the gun barrel
of zeus he's going to try and catch him
out lurk up closely he sees him coming
nice shot by simple there's two
one to go seized they don't know they're
there
the desperate play in 2b comes in smokes
let's get double smokes in the same
place there simple just jumping casually
into the side he's going to fall down
and get him
down right what is it simple are you
serious what is that you can't do that
simple that's not allowed this is not
fpl this is a major
simple i don't know man if he just comes
in with that
there's no scope he didn't even he had
we had one bite on his mouth
he had one button there was no zoom make
no mistake
simple could be one unbearable son of a
[ __ ] but
north american counter-strike was in no
shortage of those
and nobody went after those players the
way they
went after him needless to say simple's
stint in north america didn't end up
working out
in the end the differences between him
and his teammates were too much to
overcome
so in august of 2016 a simple returned
to ukraine and ran into the loving arms
of the one
org he'd always dreamed of joining and
the thing that actually mattered to him
the most
his family but that doesn't mean that
his overseas expedition was a
total failure after all it gave us the
single sickest highlight of his career
and brought liquid to the brink of
two major wins and perhaps most
importantly
it taught him a valuable lesson when it
comes to playing well with others
and lord knows he's put it to good use
and look at electronic he's just exuding
confidence he hasn't let go of w but
he's punished for it
nexter now has a krieg to fight this one
off and kenny
he's not going down without a fight
interesting maneuver a championship
point i have to say but still they're
making it work
two versus two and it's going to be
simple and flamey who just seemed to be
taking matters into their own hands
ladies and gentlemen
there it is your champions are going to
be navi it's a 3-0
clean sweep here in the grand final
while the simple of
old has been known to rear his ugly head
from time to time
so [ __ ] oh my god sorry he's made
huge strides as a cooperative competitor
people knew simple as the game's most
selfish prodigy but he has matured into
a
team-oriented superstar only two weeks
and we destroyed everyone
sorry teams i'm just kidding just
that's a great moment thanks perfecto
bluemix and blade for coming in this
team thanks to our
psychologists as well like without all
of them
i think we couldn't do what we did now
simple may be a deity in
the server but if he's learned anything
from his experience overseas
it's that he's just as human as the
teammates he'd made a habit of putting
down
that if his roster was ever going to
truly get on his
level they'd need to be bolstered not
bullied
flame he's gone down and out just
perfecto and simple he needs a
multi-kill
first found twist aggressing they have
to double peak he's getting his shot
he's here
simple oh simple that's unbelievable
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again
[Music]
yeah i love it dude i love the why you
bullying me why are you bullying me
everyone asking it's just so [ __ ]
good
it's so [ __ ] good dude super sedum
honestly gave this meme life dude he
just gave it to life
it's so funny that guy's doing god's oh
he's doing god's work
i was so happy that he gave us that
shout out on the stewie like when he
wrote in our comments he was just like
great
i was so happy i was like dude super
cinema honestly like super sedum is the
goat
he's the [ __ ] goat dude he's so good